welcome to Martin Freeman's life advice
with me Martin Freeman featuring Martin
Freeman reading genuine questions from
actual made-up people this is a very
American question I started dating a guy
who's really into soccer football said
the rest of the [ __ ] world and I'm
trying to learn everything I can before
the World Cup where should I start don't
call it soccer because that's a dent it
just football the rest of planet Earth
calls it football to start there I hate
it I hate every single one of my wife's
friends I'm worried she has bad taste in
people does this reflect badly on me
since she chose me as a life mate it's
only her friends you're her real special
friend a hateful man this is another
question from a real made-up person I
have a friend who always insists on
paying for dinner to the point where
it's kind of ridiculous
is he trying to emasculate me or am I
reading too much into it he's not taking
obviously not taking your feelings into
consideration otherwise you wouldn't be
feeling like this he should ask you but
more to the point you should tell him
maybe rather than asking you an English
actor my wife tells me she doesn't
believe in God but for some reason once
our three-year-old son - I'm a serious
atheist is there any other kind should I
indulge her yeah you should indulge her
I think you should but you should keep
talking about it I know I don't know
what's happening now is it that did that
Mike again
like in modern our that was life advice
with me Martin Freeman giving advice to
the people who've written in to Martin
Freeman yeah thank you for watching and
far goes on soon watch that you'll enjoy
it and that was the reason I believe
that I was here in the first place so um
thank you all for having
[Music]